now our forebears and all these
different tried to understood that there
was another element in spiritual
transformation and I say our forebears
because modern folk have gone real sort
of brain-dead on this one and begun to
act this out unconsciously and that is
sacrifice sacrifice is always a part of
authentic spiritual transformation now
what was it that our ancestors knew and
I don't mean just the de Gaulle wrong
although they knew it if you've studied
with Martine you know that the Mayans
knew it well the Jews knew it and the
Zoroastrians into it and so on
what is it that they knew well there is
something great it wants something from
me if I want the resources I need for
life I'm going to have to offer it what
it wants and if I offer it something
worthy maybe it will return something
back to me that will enable me to live
me and my family me and my community me
and my village in my world you follow
that now so that that is died just
recently did did a seminar on the
archetype of sacrifice
and and in the course of studying this
doing cross-cultural studies of
sacrifice though those are the elements
this sacrifice element we've now learned
you know it can be either conscious or
unconscious so in other words here's the
situation you will sacrifice period I
may know I may feel deeply in my bones
that that that there needs to be a
sacrifice and I may well decide it's you
that needs to be sacrificed
human beings have had a long history of
that but we're going to sacrifice you in
order that the world continued to work
there's always sacrifice it's whether
you know you're sacrificing or not
you're going to sacrifice okay so that's
number six
now if sacrifice is done consciously it
is possible to enter into an ongoing
communion with the great two primal
other in which the flow between you and
it gets to be a sort of beneficent flow
when that flow is established if you can
get into this communion consciously then
a lot of things are possible that is to
say you will not have an energy shortage
and your courage will be better and your
susceptibility to despair will go way
down and that is when you you you
actually can it is actually possible for
you to experience radiance this is
when what has been called indwelling
occurs this is when what has been called
illumination occurs some of you have
told me that you're very serious about
your own realization of the God within
you our ancestors witnessed that it's
usually accompanied by by a kind of new
car a new level of love a new level of
peace you and I could say that then you
can have passion and you can have the
kind of passion that you would need it
to really care about justice in the
world
so those seven elements I think are the
last two conscious sacrifice conscious
offering the power of conscious offering
and entering into communion with the
primal other the great other however
your tribe conceived those take you to
sort of the farther reaches of spiritual
realization and but there are all of
these elements are present if you you
study any any tradition of spirituality
and you look closely there these
elements are present well there's this
story in the New Testament and it's
about the feeding of the 5,000 and and
all these folks he's hungry tired folks
that have been following Jesus it's
getting toward night foam and they're
they're really tired and they're hungry
and there's not anything for them you
all know this story most most of you do
and when they kind of asked what what
have we got well we got five loaves and
two fishes and so Jesus asked that they
be brought to him and he took them and
he blessed them
very imperfect resources and lo and
behold suddenly there was enough to feed
all these people
and after everyone dined they picked up
all these baskets of things left over
all right and that's about offering
that's about what happens when you bring
an imperfect fragmentary offering
authentically to the great one that is
you know I'm not Roman Catholic but
that's acted out every time the mass is
celebrated that's why young was so
fascinated by the transformation
symbolism in the mass and that's why
young believed that if you look deeply
into the heart of alchemy you will see a
inner sacrifice that is modeled on the
mass in the heart of alchemy so in any
case offering and it's not but that's
true in Christianity but it's not just
true in Christianity it is that bringing
see some traditions thought you had to
bring the perfect offering but you know
that's a little grandiose you have to
bring authentically your fragmented
offering but if you bring it
authentically the great one can multiply
to give it back to you in a form you can
receive and use to fuel your life